hills and winds we've played before
from australia let's do it for another
uh
10-0 game
all right hills and winds
um
what do i want to play against hills and
winds can i get any idea from this
position
i don't think so oh maybe maybe i played
e4 in that game i have a pawn on e5
um
let's try e4 again
if i even played e4 in that game who
knows
okay
uh we're gonna go with the knight to f3
what are we gonna see d5 no
all right i guess
roy lopez land
no bishop c4
okay
not excited about winning a pawn
queen d4
this guy's indirectly defended
let's flick in cease c3
i don't want to see black easily get rid
of their uh
their knight for my king knight
all right well this has certainly
sharpened up
is f5 a good move
can i let me revisit this capture
now that i have control over d4 if i
swipe here
take back
and then take here
i don't think they have time to take
here because i i'm
when i take here i'm threatening this
let's see chop chop chop
what are some
annoying looking moves
a queen g5
i don't think is
a great idea
i have d4 there queen takes
queen takes g2 i have queen f3 to defend
f2 and my rook
or do i is there bishop f2 in that
position
no no wait a sec
oh chewing up a lot of time here i
realize but this is already super sharp
hills and winds
boom boom boom
boom
oh no what am i talking about i have d4
in that position so here here there
isn't a thread on f2 okay
uh so forget about that i think things
are cool for me in that variation should
they go for that
i'm gonna i'm gonna go for this
swipe the knight
and then take here
i should have been looking at uh maybe
bishop takes f2
i don't think bishop takes f2 straight
away is good though
all right they're they're clearly booked
up here so what's the story if i if i go
here
with check and then they uh
and then they block
and i take
they have knight f6
um i back
off i mean isn't queen h5 good
queen h5 g6
chop
knight f6 on my queen
queen
h5
then the rook moves here
but
can't i still play something good there
it's getting a little too what's the say
can maybe i'm i'm leaning towards
something safer now
could i get a developing move in first
maybe d4
really booked up i'm pretty sure with
this line and i'm not
so
that's what i'm thinking at least
should i revisit this queen h5
g6
take
knight f6 queen h5 rook g8
uh they're going to be castling queen
side i don't like that that rook is
staring there
maybe knight here d4
i'm gonna go with d4
after all that
yeah after all that
we'll see if it's
if it settles down a little oh they're
thinking this mustn't have been book
move
all right yeah so opposite color bishops
these
guys um
can i make life difficult for them to
castle
queenside i don't want to see queenside
castles
hmm
i have the healthier uh structure i have
four to three
on the queen side
f4 i think i may want to might want to
play
my light squares
this is going to be tough
my king may be a struggling piece
all right i'm going to be i'm going to
begin with uh
let me begin with this
i don't know
four minutes
ooh all right i i have my eye on this e3
square i may want to put my knight there
uh i guess i could consider trying to
track the e4 pawn down
maybe all right let's begin with that at
least where else is that clown gonna go
okay hang on for a second
am i
kinda close to winning that pawn now
rookie one
let's give it a go
um
yeah let's let's give it a go they can't
castle
i'd take the knight
i'd much rather take the knight only
after they maybe move their king they'd
have that move yeah i could get out of
the pin
so
let's do it
we're out of the pin
um king here i'm really asking for
trouble that move i didn't see
huh
how about that
all right
what if i play f4
just exchanging here knight g6
here and then here oh
okay
hmm
way down on the clock
huh
wow
um
i'm gonna go with
i don't know i'm gonna go with f4
um maybe i should have captured the
knight first but i'm really helping out
their development
have all their pieces working these two
clowns
i don't know
i'm threatening to win upon
i have a threat at least
so if they take on poisson how am i
recapturing
i don't think so much about that they
have some in-between
in-betweeners type stuff that's
a little too disruptive
we shall see
if
knight g6 is played there's this as a
threat
i could uh play this move though
and uh h6 i have this fallback square
maybe i end up winning this pawn
still though it's scary
being so many moves away from completing
development
a knight on this square here
i'd be a fan of that
they're in the tank the first time
my opponent is really in the tank here
and uh yeah that's not surprising
whenever there's an opportunity to have
different structures surface
you're trying trying your best to assess
which one your pieces
are uh
you know which structure
structure a how how will my pieces be in
that one
structure b will they be better here
that kind of stuff
what i play here is black
um
maybe i would take
this is a connected past pawn
if they don't pull the trigger on
e takes f
we shall see
other candidate moves maybe um
i don't know
h6
i was going to say that castle no they
can't castle
are they looking at a push
not sure really opening that up okay so
they are going with the knight there
okay
pretty much locked into that one
gotta save by bishop
so
am i not gonna win this pawn now
still
it's not
clear
because this battery eventually forming
on the d file
it's scary
i don't have a piece that could kind of
clog things up
on the d file
this was their plan
okay well
i if i take uh it's opening up way way
way too much
so we're gonna take here
i am threatening a fork so knight on f6
that's uh
i didn't expect that one
i think i think that might
be giving me some opportunities here
knight g3
let's go with knight g3
hitting the bishop i want to get this in
maybe bishop there
oh no different approach here
so tricky
so tricky
my time too
here and then this
the rook is going to get to the f file
i'm so down on time
let's try this 41 seconds i mean this is
that was probably not the uh
okay i wasn't expecting that one
be down a pond soon
so rook takes here i could still take
there yeah
feels like it should be a draw
well hang on maybe i could
think about winning now
but not not with the clock yeah
why'd i play that exactly
yeah this can't be right what i'm doing
here
21 seconds
i don't know if i'm in time
13 ticaronis
the king is cut off
tough tough tough
if rooker g3 i step my king up first
is that a move
i think i'll take the a pawn
give this check first and then here
10 seconds
time
they resigned
who
i don't know if i was going to pull that
one off if they did something sneaky
with the rook move
two
okay
very good game hills and wins
um
yeah i really did a good job of chewing
up a ton of time in the opening there
that was way way way too intense all
right let's see how i could have
how we both could have maybe done better
um i'm thinking i'm
definitely lost
in that ending i'm expecting some ups
and downs yeah
wow
yeah this opening here
that's pretty sharp what's the name of
it
f5
roy lopez classical variation central
variation and
this is the cordell gambit
really all right that's news to me i'm
not familiar with the cordell gambit so
look at how
yeah after h6 it's minus five
that's how bad it was for me
so it's already super difficult right
here
when i play that i'm toast knight g6 a
best move
this is where my opponent spent a bunch
of time and it paid off
you know
did find a best move there
but before we're even there let's see
how i could have approached this
differently here so i want to look at
this
this continuation first of all after f5
is my reaction good
take the knight it likes best d4
okay
now i want to quickly look at this this
and this
and after queen h5 this is what i spent
the bulk of my time on i feel
right
yeah right here so
good two minutes in this position
another
two minutes on that move
in 10 minute game
not the most efficient way so is this
problem for me
g6
chop knight f6
here
rook here
thought about e5 but yeah i just didn't
like this position
right here like they're they're getting
their pieces out the bishop's going to
move their queen is going to move their
king's going to be cozy
these guys are all still spectators on
the queen side
all right
all right
next time play d4 i guess
open the position up
and uh
yeah
if this move
now i could chop here
and then here oh yeah
and then this is uh
much better now that i have d4 in
okay d4 right here
okay
why didn't i consider d4 at all
is this really a bother oh look at that
reaction capture i have e5
alpha zero pawn
loves that pawn on e5 and then i could
play some gambit i'm usually not a big
fan of sacrificing pawns but i see the
advantage in this situation
speedy development
the usual case with gambits
okay
so what's the real knockout i guess
as a close to this one
what's the knockout that black has
that's good
that's good
g5 is a cool follow-up it doesn't like
g5 but man i felt that that was a slick
move
g5
still holds an advantage for black but
right here bishop h7
with what is the idea
uh if i chop here
rook f8
and how am i how am i stopping this
i'm in trouble
so this this seemed like them
a really nice way to break down my
position
for sure create this tension create open
lines certainly if i capture in one way
or the other this rook is
boom bright
brought right to life
but
how about that for a patient move huh
after i take here
or instead of g5
simply dropping the
or drop dropping the bishop back or
playing rook here first and then
dropping the bishop back
there's no good defense right here
well it's a little bit slow looking but
yeah once the that second rook is
activated
trouble city and i didn't really see a
good
way here i thought about this here and
then that but rook f8
these guys are out of control
and i can't step my king up
and i don't think i could get away with
going into a discovered check
if i tried that something
something's going to hurt me i go here
i'm maybe getting mated rook d3
here
yeah that's a mate
okay
so
advantage for a while there for black
rook h6 ooh rook h6
and then you're getting here that that
was a win for black
and then
i guess it turns where coming up
another win here with g4 first yeah
right because what i do i ended up
harassing this pawn a little bit
and that caused some inconvenience for
black
and now it's winning actually for me
barely
barely barely barely
okay
excellent game hills and wins thank you
for playing that sharp opening i learned
learned something there
you